being numbered soup has never looked so
good honey and number two is the new
number one blue night angel show us all
who are you take
[Applause]
well congratulations miss Knight angel
thank you all so you are a liar because
when we talked to months ago and I asked
you about the masked singer you played
so coy and you know everybody and their
brother thinks you're I normally lied to
you okay I would have been breaking the
rules you were lying by omission you
played very coy but how hard of a secret
was this to keep oh my gosh it was so
hard like everybody has been texting me
calling me posting messages on social
media and about the show and I could not
respond I couldn't respond I couldn't
like the comments I couldn't even you
know like a post about mask singer
because I didn't want to confirm to
anybody that I was are there and yet we
knew because you have a very distinctive
voice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the good thing in the music industry
makes keeping a secret of the masked
singer a little more difficult when you
can pinpoint someone's voice so much
listen I tried to give you guys a fake
British accent for like most diseases
like an angel I felt deeply blessed my
entire life yeah why where did where did
that idea come from because you know the
first okay so when they first said that
I should do the show that I was gonna do
the show I was like okay cool that told
my family if my daughter was like
everybody's gonna know it's you as soon
as you open your mouth and so I was like
okay well maybe I should do an exit and
you know maybe that'll throw people off
you know that didn't throw any body up
that's like all the artwork I'll put it
to this exit and no it didn't fool
anybody you know you put in the work you
tried which is all you can do and you
won so it paid off to be the first woman
to win the mass singer
your amazing performance
[Applause]
and I just really appreciate you guys
for helping me build my confidence back
up I love you said that the show renewed
your confidence in yourself what did you
learn about yourself by going through
this very strange experience I think
being able to perform and not be judged
and I was just being judged by my voice
in the performance only like I feel like
every day and like especially being on
the Real Housewives of Atlanta you know
I have people that just dog me out or
say crazy stuff about me for any reason
like they'll just say you know oh she
can't sing you know this is and all
these different things that are negative
so I just started feeling like well
maybe people just don't like my voice I
mean but being on the show and getting
all that positivity from the judges and
their uplifting me every week and then I
was secretly going online and looking at
the comments from fans of masked singer
to see what they say it was like oh nine
angel killed it and it made me feel good
that so many people were fans of the
night angel which is weak alright moving
off of a night angel let's talk about
miss unforgettable miss aren't begin
opal unforgettable or forgettable this
reunion is next-level candy how do you
feel about that virtual reunion oh my
god hilarious I honestly did not think
that it was gonna be as good as it is
because I was like how do we know sit up
here and argue with people on on a
computer like that could make sense to
me and then I felt like a lot of people
would not really face up to whatever
they needed to because they're not right
there in your faces which I was right
about one thing people can just walk
away from the computer when they got you
know under fire
where's Nene what but um it's it's her
not really good I think what you think
oh I've been enjoying it I I'm waiting
to see if Nene even appears in part
three because she walked away do you
know if she's gonna show up I want
everybody to remember she really went
around and told the whole world that she
was going to read us and that she was
gonna let us have it and all this stuff
so please know that we were not the
reason why she got up and left
the real reason why she got up and left
was because yovanna posted a post to let
everybody know that she was about to
come on the show like two minutes after
yovana posted it that is when Nene got
up
we weren't even talking to Nene anymore
when she got it don't let her fool y'all
she did not want to face the things that
you say clearly she's afraid of the
truth going in through Union I kind of
thought the snake gate thing had been
resolved to like the extent that it was
going to be resolved and then I guess
we're taking a left turn at the Reunion
it was a little bit more to her than
none
you provided a quote that I'll be saying
for the rest of my life watching you and
Nene go at it was like peak reunion TV
did you know that it was gonna hit that
point to be honest with you she and I
had like a argument over text messages
that was reading each other on the text
messages just me her nobody else was
involved it's just as she and I and I
just stopped responding to her at a
certain point because I was like I
realize this lady is really just gonna
keep going back and forth for me on this
text message and we over here really
being childish right now ah but from
that I knew that it was gonna be ugly
at the Reunion because I was like if
we're doing this on a text between Shia
and I cuz
clearly we're gonna be going for blood I
already knew she was gonna be you know
doing what she does okay whatever she
wanted to do I was gonna match her
energy she came crazy I was gonna come
crazy wearing so that's basically a
happy that is what happened do you think
you guys can reconcile or I mean we
reconciled before we made a conscious
effort to do better with each other but
this year is when we reverted back to
the drama I personally didn't know where
it started I felt like it started when
he and Eva got on TV and start telling
everybody I made more money than need to
you I mean she's the top biller that's
not true so who makes the most in the
line that makes the most money okay okay
so if I was coming for anybody's purse
and bag it would be Kandi's me started
you know saying little stuff oh you need
to watch candy and all this negative
crazy stuff like what is our problem but
I felt like that's where it came from
and it just kids grown from there but
I'm just gonna match her energy she's
telling me crazy I'm with you for crazy
and you know I can't help that we were
in quarantine because I have time now
okay whatever but now because I'm just
sitting at home I'm like okay you got
the right one today
I chatted with your girl came tomorrow
yesterday and she says she's the one who
could bring you two together I really
want to be the person to get her and
Nene together I hate that they're
arguing I hate that they're fighting I
haven't really even spoken to candy or
Nene since the hole because I'm just so
disappointed
I hate it so much and I told you me
before that I've really got a chance to
get to know kandi in the Big Brother
house and they have a lot of
similarities and they should just spend
some time with each other they probably
would really really like each other
that's what I that listen to whatever I
was talking about
I love Tamar but sometimes I feel like
Tamar's a little biased in her thoughts
I mean maybe because she's only really
talked to Nene about the situation and I
don't really think she gets my point of
view because I don't even feel the need
to even go and try to explain it for
real hey then be honest with you I don't
much love to take more but if Nene and I
if we reconcile it'll be in the next
season how about that all right but
where do you think this group goes from
here Nene says she thinks - peach
holders need to go so that it's not
doesn't feel like the same carousel of
drama next season I want everybody on
the show to stop telling everybody who
they think should go here's the thing
none of us are the decision makers on
who can go and who can stay so I think
we need to stop trying to hate on other
people's jobs and throwing salt on other
people on the show because everybody's
there for a reason and if they're not
supposed to be there then probably will
decide that's the way I look at it and
I'm just gonna leave it at that but I
will want to tell y'all is to get this
new single
yeah yeah well my king I call Josiah now
you're the one who made me cry God but
sinners now are you I like it is so good
and it's a departure from this candy
sound we've heard before yes it's on
purpose I told you being on this show
has helped me reinvent myself in a way
so I really wanted to just give people
something they could dance to and I want
everybody to be able to dance and I
wanted it to be one of those the records
they're just like as soon as it comes on
like you start moving or the body just
starts going yeah you know and so that's
what I did
my new song used to love me it's already
starting to do well on the chart and so
I'm excited about it
well congrats on that I'll be putting it
on my playlist with Nene's song people
always try to compare the two songs or
whatever it's a way I feel about it much
love there I don't feel like we have to
be compared to music you know no two
different places well good to see you
thanks for this and happy belated
birthday thank you and let me say this
and this is just a little this is just
being a little pity not being number two
has never looked so good honey
and number two is the new number one
blue you know what you know what you
want 1 million or two new why show or
two shows
[Music]